You've had the minimum edition in your
hands for the last 48 hours. You've seen
the trap score. You felt what it's like
to have a shield. But while you're
watching the score, the whales are
already evolving. The minimum edition
shows you the door, but the full
protocol shows you the entire room.
Right now, institutional algorithms are
layering fake signals to trigger your
FOMO. When the trap snaps, a minimum
shield might not be enough. You need the
full visual intelligence suite. Four AI
engines, Grock, GPT, Gemini, and
CryptoQuant working in sync. Real-time
whale tracking, sentiment filters,
3-second decision-making. This isn't
just trading, it's an unfair advantage.
To celebrate our new defenders, we are
opening the protocol campaign. For the
next 50 people only, you can unlock
everything at 50% off. That's full
institutional protection for less than a
dollar a day. But once those 50 spots
are taken, this link expires and the
price doubles. Don't leave your capital
to chance. Upgrade your defense
protocol. Use code defend 50 at checkout
right now. Welcome to the full academy.
Let's win together.